oh what you think you're better than me
up your button around the corner but
this got you you've been told before
your jelly got
cold hi everyone Scott Grimes here I
play Maddie Bennett in the new peacock
series Ted and I'm Ryan Reynolds and I
play mty's wife Susan Bennett the series
takes place in 1993 so to refresh your
memory we are going to be talking about
some '90s
slang and thises dises here we go
okay it's a Vibe thing it's Vibe I think
it's like it's it's like go
yourself yeah it's like up your butt and
around the corner up your butt and
around the corner 15 miles and out the
other
end psych was if you give somebody
something like here you want to hold my
hat
psychs psych like in your face you know
psych take a chill pill a poop and eat
some fruit loops for God's sake chill
out chill take XX take it out ofan okay
yeah uh just
relax like extra food came with my Uber
Eats order hell yeah
booah let's party let's raise the roof
let's have a good time Ro lower the
floor yeah lower the floor raise the
roof no that music wasn't there yet
let's turn up yeah raise roof yeah there
you
go What's the 411 what's the scoop
what's the Stitch what's the deal what's
the tea what's the what's the tea te big
time Big Time
tea no duh all right just use duh duh
that's me texting duh double du really
triple du nope don't ever triple du
anybody does that count as 90 I feel
like I say that all the time yeah all
the time no duh like like like of course
I say that all the time are you stupid
make sure you check out Ted streaming
now on peacock I'll see you around like
a
donut I'll do like a tree get out of
[Music]
here